la langue française est une très très
précises qui a beaucoup de mots pour
dire pudeur et à la vergogne via la
réserve qu'un certain ou de mots et
beaucoup de l'homme n'ont pas ces mots
là la timidité aussi on en fait partie
ou pardon la timidité c'est le versant
négatif et je parle moi d'une qualité
positive et la langue française est très
riche dans ses bras et c'est une langue
qui demande d'un effet la pudeur la
réserve est une sorte de sous-évaluation
ce qu'on appelle dans la forme la plus
évoluée la litote isolant de la litote
alors qu'au contraire il ya des langues
comme la langue anglaise par exemple qui
manque au contraire extrêmement riche et
ainsi de suite
la deuxième raison est est issu du
métier parce que lorsqu'on publie ce
qu'on fait des livres vous entendez vous
publiez publication on met tout soi-même
dans ses livres d'une certaine manière
on s'étale en public quoique on soit
publique veillé et donc ajouter à cette
publication de la publicité est une
sorte d'addiction que je ne supporte que
mal vous voyez ce que je veux dire quand
vous écrivez vous parlez beaucoup de
vous en fait on est forcé de parler de
soi puisque d'une certaine manière comme
dit l'autre le style c'est l'homme et
que le style et anti limite à bhl
personnel subjectif et n'appartenant
finalement qu'à choix on est tout le
temps en train de faire voire le soin ce
mois là que ce soit autobiographie alors
raison c'est pas autobiographique bien
entendu parce que je parle de ça même si
je faisais un traité de mathématiques
c'est quand même mon style dont il ya
une publication de soi même c'est à dire
une exhibition de soi même à l'extérieur
qui suffit largement samcon plus on vous
demande des choses voilà c'est à michel
serres ça va vous déplaire mais bertrand
d'âge et vanilla nous rejoindre et va
parler de vous
catherine bonjour voir moi aussi aimé
une question michel serres est il
accessible
oui comme peut l'être le sommet d'une
montagne alors justement une condition
choisir la bonne voie celle qui nous
correspond celle qui nous va tout
d'abord on exclut toute triche celle qui
consisterait à prétendre qu'on a
escaladé alors qu'en fait on s'est fait
héliporter le mensonge ne tiendrait pas
longtemps
ridicule au même titre qu il serait
ridicule après s'être gavé de citations
mal comprises de tenter de jouer avec
vos philosophes n'ont d'ailleurs vous
fixé quelques bazin on n'est pas
philosophe si on n'a pas lieu platon
descartes espinosa chercher la moindre
des choses c'est mon corps se dévoilent
alors cherchons à notre passage
un lieu un lien qu'on pourrait d'avoir
en commun un lieu de bachy suis moi
aussi tout cas vous et beaucoup d'autres
j'ai vécu à moulinsart
oui très bien un lien oui tintin c'est
un ami d'enfance
alors on écrit mon énergie et mon avis
je crois que vous avez ouvert une voie
d'accès jubilatoire à la philosophie est
qu'en parfois au gré de votre vos buts
sur quelques mots comme ça qui vous sont
familiers keanu sont bien souvent ne
sont bien souvent étrangers je pensais à
taxinomie apex ou inter cinématiques
sina petit pardon synaptique chez lâcher
la voulait il est le parcours n'hésitons
pas sans une once de honte prenons au
dictionnaire il ya longtemps qu'on
aurait dû le faire faut être précis
depuis le premier tintin parce que quand
le capitaine haddock et ruth des
zapotèques amphitryon bachi bouzouk tout
le monde ne sait pas de quoi il s'agit
à y réfléchir il ya peut-être un peu de
tintin en vous le côté seul contre tous
attendant je crois à vous dopez je pense
edith cresson 92 elle vous avez confié
un rapport sur la mission d'étude pardon
sur les enseignements à distance et
après avoir rendu son rapport va vous
avez déclaré vu son jus son accueil mon
rapport a reçu 1 d accord global ce qui
est très bon signe
la classe politique le refuser les
journalistes le haïssent vous auriez
peut-être aussi un zeste un zeste
seulement du professeur tournesol
parfois parti que vous êtes dans des
réflexions philosophiques à apporter
intergalactique faut bien reconnaître
que le commun des mortels a parfois du
mal
suivre alors vous et le capitaine
haddock là c'est moins évident l'alcool
le tabac non la bordée de jurons
peut-être je vais faire un test
michel serres parlez moi de vous
racontez moi vos vacances en détail avec
qui et où étiez-vous aux dernières
vacances je te caches tout plus de
vacances à la montagne jean duron et là
ça va mieux après plus de 35 ans
d'amitié second jeune tam entraîne dans
une nouvelle aventure
je vais vous lire et qui sait après
j'attaque platon descartes spinoza
tiens je crois que ça alors ça laisse
sans voix nos amis oui regardez michel
serres la syrie n'a repris vos les
personnages de votre ami hergé le
capitaine haddock et ont souhaité que
vous puissiez tout simplement
personnaliser les bulles parce qu'elles
sont bien vides
m oui remplir les buts qu'est ce que
vous y mettrez y est là il est en train
d'appeler la boucherie sanzot nous
peut-être imaginer ce que serait il faut
écrire oui bien sûr allô la boucherie
sang qu'est-ce que vous inspire cette
attaque avec ce mille ou en promenade
dans les bois à mon avis doit faire de
la philosophie pas très contents avant
histoire de la philosophie il doit il
doit dire et ils doivent sortir de la
lecture de plateau ou du besoin de
prendre l'air et même que c'est
d'ailleurs oui vous savez que elle a
chanté le 1er avril à bordeaux à l'opéra
de bordeaux
l'opéra de bordeaux a organisé pour le
1er avril et parce que c'était le 1er
avril
un récital de bianca castafiore qui
chantait l'air des bijoux
où et qui était tout le temps
interrompue par milou en train d'aboyer
par l'arrivée du capitaine haddock en
train de faire des jurons et cetera ça a
été une soirée explosive
j ai assisté j'ai même fait un petit
texte pour le programme de l'opéra il y
avait bien entendu la veuve d'hergé son
nouveau mari et c est à la fin de la
cérémonie où il y avait bien entendu le
autocar portant son sceptre avec ça avec
avec la reine on a assisté à la
décoration du maire de bordeaux monsieur
juppé dans l'ordre du grand public en
noir qui si votre élève et et il a fait
un discours extraordinaire en disant
qu'il soutenait beaucoup la politique de
la syldavie devant les mener bordure ça
a été une soirée
donc madame castafiore je les ai vus en
réalité ma chaise j'ai mon ami pourquoi
vous avez attendu si longtemps pour pour
l'écrire
et bien voilà parce que c'est une
histoire d'amitié avec la veuve d'hergé
que je connais encore et que j'aime
beaucoup qui s'appelle fadli d'ailleurs
le livre lui est dédicacé et à partir
d'un certain moment c'est c'est elle qui
m'a téléphoné un jour en me disant vous
avez fait beaucoup de textes si vous en
ajoutez 4 ou 5 vous pourriez peut-être
faire un livre pour nous et c'est et
c'est un lieu qui est publié aux
éditions moulinsart
donc j'ai habité comme vous abou nassar
et et j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à le
faire à nommage à celui qui a été ce que
j'appelle mon ami de vieillesse c'est à
dire avec qui j'ai eu 20 ans à peu près
vingt ans d'amitié soutenu est tout à
fait proches et admirative quelques
années
un livre un ouvrage qui a été écrit par
cars assouline sur hergé qui était un
jeu dirait vraiment un livre donc assez
assez méchant d'ailleurs j'ai quand on
est très très quand on a beaucoup de
gloire etc
on attire beaucoup on déconne
paratonnerre alors on attire la foudre
mais quand on dit kg et est
réactionnaire qui était sensible aux
idées d'extrême droite et madame il ya
une réponse très simple à faire face à
ces dangers que la plupart des mes
contemporains de mes enfants et de mes
petits enfants ont appris l'amour des
autres l'amour de 2,2 du petit de du
petit tintin pour chiang chinois c'est
lui qui protège au rhino l'indian
amérique du sud il n'y a pas deux
oeuvres qui pousse le plus à l'amitié
entre les peuples
qu'est-ce qui viennent dire sept veulent
acquis pendant la guerre a été notre
bouffée d'oxygène car enfin c'était très
dur
elle nous a appris l'amitié entre les
peuples et par conséquent c'est c'est
tout à fait le contraire je ne comprends
pas comment hergé puisse être accusé de
cette manière voyez comment l'avez vous
rencontrée je les rencontre et parce que
à un certain moment j'avais trouvé que
la sphère tournesol mais les bijoux de
la castafiore étaient de très très beaux
textes sur tel était le sujet de
philosophie dont je ne parlerai pas
[Musique]